[Musique]
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 le débat
l'émission est consacrée à une question
qui fait débat depuis 14 ans la
sélection à l'entrée en master alors la
droite y est favorable et de son côté la
gauche souhaite que des étudiants et en
droit à la poursuite des études alors
faut-il une sélection à l'entrée au
master pour en débattre avec tous ce
soir myriam ou corgnet vous êtes
responsable de la section unis et vous
êtes contre nm chili ici présent
président de l'unef jean et de votre
côté vous êtes contre mon soir à vous
deux on va vous donner la parole madame
corgnet pourquoi vous êtes contre donc
ça très fort donc voulu par najat
vallaud belkacem donc ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de
l'enseignement supérieur
pause a le droit à la poursuite des
études tout en parlant de recrutement or
ce droit à la pensée des études va
générer et déjà un conflit entre le
rectorat et les présidents d'université
tout d'abord parce que le rectorat aura
une obligation de proposer trois choix à
chaque étudiant qui n'aura pas eu le
masters qui n qu'il souhaitait or des
présidents d'université ont rendez-vous
des soucis et donc ça va créer après des
facs d'excellence et des facs on va dire
bas de gamme entre guillemets ça va
faire également des filières voie de
garage et des filières d'excellence et
de plus ça va à l'encontre de la loi
d'autonomie voté par valérie pécresse il
ya quelques années alors vous êtes
d'accord avec ces propos vous qui est
pour sûr que non qu'est ce qui vous pose
problème alors d'abord pour bien aborder
ce débat pour voir un peu la situation
dans laquelle on était dans une
situation dans laquelle l'homme est la
section avait lieu entre le master 1
master 2 qui fait que le destin a
commencé un master en sans savoir s'ils
pouvaient bien le finir là la france est
la première chose vaut pour tous les
postes pas pour tous les masters mais
pour 40 % respectivement
pas mal qu'on avait une section de la un
peu un peu floue en 2001
des étudiants attaquer l'université en
justice donc on a une situation qui
était intenable et sur lequel tout le
monde le géant en 2015 d'ailleurs les
étudiants
les étudiants le presseur et les prisons
universel et il fallait réformer le
masters alors c'est quoi cette réforme
c'est effectivement met en place la
section non pas un master l'issue du
masters mais issu de la licence qui
permet d'avoir un vrai bloc ce qu'une
cohérence pédagogie c'est à dire pendant
la troisième licence et deux vrais
animateurs et céder la vraie la chose
pour laquelle nous nous sommes
satisfaits de ce premier c'est
effectivement le droit la poursuite
d'études ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui sa
garantie à tout étudiant qui veut
poursuivre des études et qui veut avoir
un diplôme de master de continuer ses
études dans la filière aux anchois et
dans son université et ça c'est une
vraie victoire pour les étudiants nous
ce qu'on disait on est opposé à la
section auster cas on veut pouvoir
permettre à l'ensemble des étudiants au
plus grand monde du monde de réussir en
cinq universités eh bien grâce à ce
qu'on premier on a une première victoire
le fait que demain on aura moins 100 %
des étudiants qui pourront avoir un
diplôme de master à l'issue de leur
parcours universitaire et c'est pour ça
que c'est une vraie victoire est
conseillé satisfaits de ce compromis
mais cette sélection va pas créer une
des masters vraiment à deux vitesses
parce que certains étudiants ont un très
bon en fait ils seront dans les
meilleurs masters mais après ça va ça va
faire des masters sélectif est petit
mais après il y aura des masters bas de
gamme on va dire on va mettre tous les
étudiants qui n'auront pas eu leur
première leur premier choix mais qui
vont avoir un second et un troisième
choix qui vont se retrouver dans des
masters surchargé et qui est ça va
dévaloriser leur diplôme et donc leur
entrée dans le marché du travail or là
quand on voit que 40% des étudiants
après leur master 2 sont au chômage ou
enchaîne les cdd ou des missions
d'intérim il faut un moment mettre une
sélection et mettre une orientation sûr
et durable comme ça les étudiants à
l'issue de leur nature de aurons un
travail dans les mois qui suivent et
vous qui parlez de d'excellence le fait
que certains n'arrivent pas à accéder au
masters de leur choix ça vous fait pas
peur c'est master on va en gros fourre
tout
on ne pouvait pas se satisfaire du statu
quo c'est pour ça que débord sous
compromis même s'il n'est pas totalement
satisfait
on n'est pas en studio ce compromis mais
ce n'est pas notre position vont aller
plus loin là dessus on est quand même
satisfait c'est déjà un premier pas si
après effectivement il ya des enjeux
c'est le fait qu' on ne peut pas laisser
se créer des masters des guides des
masters poubelles dessus on est tous
d'accord sauf que c'est un mauvais point
de vue de prendre langue du fait que ben
oui parce qu'on crée le droit de pousser
d'études on va créer des masters pro
rider mettre à distance ce n'est pas le
cas pour éviter sur deux choses car ce
qu'il faut mettre en place c'est la
garantie résultats tout en étudiant et
c'est d'abord permettre d' étudiants de
réussir en licence plus actuellement il
ya instamment de d'étudiants qui échoit
en première année qui n'arrive pas à
aller au boulot sens parce qu'on a des
conditions d'études qui sont intenables
si les amphis bondés c était des
surcharges et ses failles et une pénurie
est budgétaire actuellement des
universités et c'est exactement pareil
au masters on peut garantir la réussite
à tous en master si on donne les moyens
et qui sont donne l'ambition ensuite
pour que oui on est une classe d'âge
soit diplômé oui notamment on dit cette
réforme était nécessaire pour une chose
c'est qu'en france on manque
terriblement de diplômés on estime que
d'ici 2020 la france aura deux millions
diplômés de retard ce qui montre qu'il
fallait démocratiser l'accès au master
médiatisé l'axé un master mettra tous
doigt sur ses licences et d'accepter un
master en mettant les moyens et en
s'assurant que capacité d'accueil elles
soient largement ouvertes c'est l'objet
des discussions qui relie entre
gouvernements et les rectorats durant
les prochains mois je tiens à rappeler
mon assise là dessus sur tlm en valais
c'est permettre à tous d'accéder à un
master et d'autres conditions on
ne peut pas permettre à tout le monde
d'accéder à un master on appâte
vainqueur n'a pas tous les capacités de
faire un master si déjà on mettait déjà
une sélection avec des prérequis délai
del entre le bac est la première année
avec une bonne orientation et un très
bon suivi il y aurait un taux d'échec
inférieur à ce qui est actuellement
quand on voit que 30% des étudiants
valides leur licence en trois ans ce qui
est assez surprenant
donc autant avoir des prérequis entre le
bac et leila permettre à ça à des
étudiants de faire une licence dans une
filière qui leur conviendrait émission
sûr de réussir et après d'émettre une
autre sélection à l'entraînement et main
comme ça on va pas dire à tout le monde
fait des masters parce que faire des
masters c'est bien c'est bien mais à
prix pourrait ainsi avoir un travail à
côté donc vous à l'entrée de la fac oui
vous voulez mettre un concours d avoir
des pré-requis est ce que c'est quand on
voit qu'il ya 500 épisodes fait pas
office de prérequis pour nous les bacs
et des
90 % d'une classe d'âge obtient le bac
c'est pas 4 1% m/m -2 90% matière tout
le monde a son bac maintenant mais pas
quatre oui
c'est vos propos
c'est d'avoir les bons éléments base
premièrement un diplôme ce n'est pas le
nombre de personnes qu'il obtient qui
estime sa valeur c'est combien on
investit et comment on s'assure que ce
diplôme là est une valeur en termes de
l'enseignement qu'on va lui apporter les
conditions dans quinze sentiment d'être
attribué ce n'est pas parce que 80 %
d'une classe d'âge à un bac qu'abc garde
sa valeur c'est pareil pour le terme au
bout ce n'est pas parce que beaucoup de
gens sont diplômés que ça d'ailleurs
c'est est ce qu'on met les moyens on pas
pour ce diplôme sont vraiment efficaces
que les yankee il se diplômer eu des
connaissances et des compétences qui
aujourd'hui leur permettra d'évoluer sur
un support historique sera d'abord fort
posé les bases du débat et ensuite des
nues quand même des choses ils font
satisfaire c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya
énormément personnes qui ont accès dans
son expérience était une mystification
c'est dans un mois on le voit encore ces
derniers que un peu tous ceux qui sont
nés dans le mini baby boom des années
2000 qui accèdent dans ce masters mais
ce faux site de rentreront pas dans ces
masters de l'heure et la fois ci on en
fait quoi parce que ils vont pas aller
dans ces fameux masters si on choisit
journalisme par exemple ou une école de
enfin un master en commerce vraiment
huppé et que à côté on a juste je sais
pas je prends un exemple de l'histoire
c'est pas les études qu'on voulait faire
quelque s qui fais garçons ils arrêtent
s'il retourne là bas sur le marché du
travail sont en master 2 il ya plein de
choses qu'on a dit si on est musicien et
son maçon espère le problème c'est qu'on
me dit énormément de questions et
soudain les chances pour venir il faut
bien voir les bases du débat pourquoi
pas puisque édition sont mauvais de
mauricio que soit ce parce qu on a en
étions sur dieu si vous êtes ce salarié
parce qu'il y avait assez de moyens pour
vivre au quotidien parce que là on n'a
pas les conditions idéales pour étudier
c'est tout ce qu'il faut prendre en
compte on comprendre quand même
actuellement les chaînes comme sens ça
sa première chose que l'objectif c'est
comment on démocratise la réussite de sa
mission sport et l'accent master et là
dessus c'est là où est le débat si
actuellement un étudiant qui fera les
démarches normal pour demander un master
ne pas du coup un master à l'étude ces
démarches l'a d'abord il faudra qu'on
verse t explique pourquoi ils l'ont
refusée ce qui n'était pas le cas
auparavant et chamonix v aucune
justification quant au refus ils sont
masters et à doha un peu au niveau du
jeu concours très clairement par rapport
à ça l'a poussé en fonction des forêts
c'est une perforation concours donnera
une base sur qualifiant ce préjugé et
surtout le rectorat refera trois
propositions une dont il sera
obligatoirement dans l'établissement où
l'étudiant a validé sa licence et deux
autres à l'échelle de l'académie ce qui
évite par exemple que décisions qui sont
dans la région aquitaine limousin a par
exemple sa vie ta décision de la
rochelle devoir l'étudier à limoges
serment ces choses plutôt utile et qui
évite la mobilité et surtout les trois
bus qui seront proposés par rectorat
seront obligatoirement dans parcours en
correspondant au parcours universitaire
deux élèves et aussi aux parcours
professionnels que l'élève veut mettre
la fin de son maintien c'est pour ça
qu'ils évitent on évitera la situation
il suit en histoire va se retrouver en
économie ou en étions journalistes parce
qu'on avait en biologie ou je ne sais
pas des situations qui ne feraient pas
tenable et c'est pour ça que ce
compromis et oui on est satisfait c'est
pas le meilleur compromis parce que
justement si on aurait fait 1 sélection
des le m1 et éviterait déjà à ce que des
étudiants se retrouvent sur le carreau
pour le m2 je pense qu'on est tous les
deux d'accord sur ce principe ce point
c'est la sélection d'éléments ça
permettra déjà à ce qu'il ya un coot un
suivi sur deux en m1 m2 pour les
étudiants mais là la peau là où le
compromis proposé par najat vallaud
belkacem
ça va déjà à l'encontre de la loi sur
l'autonomie des universités
mais si les présences de l'université
refusent d'écouter le rectorat comment
comment comment mon réel comment les
étudiants vont devoir réagir parce que
justement c'est un statu quo qui donne
raison à dire pour la poursuite des
études mais on recrutement mais sauf que
c'est intenable mais justement c'est
mieux logés de la loi c'est pas on se
met ensemble à l'arrêter ou un décret
c'est une wild-card et que justement
winnie dans l'amour y est on remarquer
que comme c'est le cas pour exemple
actuellement en licence tous
lycéens étudiants d'avoir un bac peut il
doit avoir obligatoirement s'il en fait
la demande d'une licence en première
mais c'est à dire que la cipa pb ils
s'en foutent ils souhaitent proposer
quoi que ce soit quand on voit un style
doit être pour une possibilité d'une
proposé une première année de licence
c'est exactement pareil avec ce qui va
se passer c'est hier le rectorat or la
commission juridique ne propose
maintenant c'est pour ça que les repas
de conflit ou de soi puisque c'est le
rectorat qui prend d'addition ça sera
chose du coup n'y a pas d'inquiétude à
avoir et la deuxième chose c'est
effectivement c'est un compromis en
gestation mais ce n'est pas l'idéal nous
ce qu'on veut c'est avec un vraie audace
une vraie ambition tonneau jendoubi et
que l'avenir on puisse avoir après
investissements pour qu'on évite cette
création de masters délit de master tout
belle île en gros nous on est pour
l'excellence mais ces licences pour tous
et ça ça doit passer par une vraie
ambition politique mais à l'abattoir n'y
a pas un statu quo entre ce truc enfin
cette deuxième chanson française
poursuite d'études et puis l'autre
partie qui va choisir qui va faire
déroulée en fait y avoir des bras de fer
justement et c'est d'étudiants qui va en
pâtir non parce que c'est la loi c'est
simplement c'est comme vous disiez ça
revient sur la loi de tony franchement
personnellement je suis satisfait parce
que la loi sur le thème universités on a
vu ce que la phase i des filières
supprimer cédé hier justement d'élite et
des filières poubelles créé par
l'université grâce est one je suis
satisfait que ce compromis ils
reviennent sur cette lola est justement
grâce au décret la loi qui seront parus
et on suivra le processus législatif qui
auront lieu dans les prochaines heures
et les prochains mois ça c'est évident
et bien ce sera le rectorat cardinaux et
le bras de fer n'a pas lieu d'être
puisque c'est du juridique et que le
rectorat permettra aux étudiants de
continuer leurs études et ça je pense
que tout le monde peut satisfaire que
oui des clients puissent continuer leurs
études et puis jour puisse faire le
parcours qui leur convient un énorme
carnet mot baba ou encore meilleur il
vaut mieux une sélection il vaut mieux
une sélection à l'entrée au m1 comme ça
ça évitera que des étudiants se
retrouvent à devoir faire des recours
auprès du rectorat et ce compromis vont
pas dans le bon sens 66 fin recrutement
mais des statu quo avec la poursuite des
études n'est pas bon du tout lâchez vous
et grâce à un premier qui sort de
l'embryon juridique qui crée ses droits
historiques certains fois ces créneaux
roy ledroit la poursuite d'études nous
on ce qu'on veut c'est loin s'est donné
les moyens financiers pour que les
masters ne soit pas surchargé avec une
puisse accueillir le plus de monde
possible c'est ce qu'on lira durant les
prochaines semaines et prochains mois et
après on le répète nous sommes quand
même opposé à la sélection puisqu'on est
pour la démocratisation d'un pont
supérieur il accélère ensuite pour tous
est ce pour ça que durant les prochaines
années à nous mèneront la bataille pour
avancer sur ce sujet là et que ce
compromis ne reste pas un statu quo
interne eh bien on n'arrivera pas à mon
pote d'abord car merci d'être venus
débattre sur ce plateau 7,8 le débat
c'est fini bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]